trouver des employés un combat de tous
les instants dans ce garage de rouyn
noranda il manque six mécaniciens mais
quand vient le temps de recruter des
travailleurs la concurrence est féroce
surtout dans une région comme l'abitibi
ou des entreprises minières sont des
employeurs de choix on est gros mais
côté salarial on peut pas les à-côtés
côté salaires les avantages sociaux
également aux autres c'est fou comment
la compétition et le on a des salaires
concurrentiels
cependant c'est très dur compétitionner
avec ses grandes machines dans l'ombre
des géants miniers plusieurs pme doivent
se tourner vers l'immigration pour
combler les postes vacants c'est le cas
chez adria où l'on fabrique des
équipements électriques de haute
puissance
l'entreprise attend avec impatience
l'arrivée de 10 travailleurs en
provenance du mexique et de la colombie
une démarche complexe et de longue
haleine c'est comme faire un saut en
parachute se doit des friches et toute
l'information et était un peu laissé à
toi même j'ai passé là aux alentours de
près huit neuf mois juste créer un
réseau de contacts à trouver toute
l'information que j'avais besoin de
comprendre pour être en mesure d'entamer
les démarches de recrutement ou
concessionnaires automobiles on a
embauché une firme de recrutement en
2016 pour dénicher trois mécaniciens aux
philippines les deux premiers sont
arrivés en mille 2018 l'autre un an plus
tard mais seul d'entre eux travaillent
toujours sur place afin d'être au
travail assez à peu près 40 mille
dollars dont le retour sur
investissement est présentement et les
héros profitable l'un des mécaniciens a
quitté pour un nouvel employeur et
l'autre pour l'ontario afin d'obtenir sa
résidence permanente plus rapidement il
y avait vu les délais si cammas était
ardue et le français aussi les vous
français au québec c'est très très dur
donc lui aient décidé d'aller en ontario
pour la voie express
le seul qui reste c'est à augusto qui a
débarqué en abitibi il ya près de trois
ans il aimerait bien que sa femme et ses
deux fils vienne me rejoindre au canada
mais pour ça il doit obtenir sa
résidence permanente
et pour y arriver il doit maîtriser le
français we need to learn prennent
québec des people pour nous c'est très
difficile dit augusto qui n'a pas encore
commencé ses cours de francisation trop
fatigué dit il après ses journées de
travail il bien candidement il pourrait
lui aussi quitter le québec pour une
autre province afin d'obtenir sa
résidence permanente
depuis près d'un an le centre local de
développement de rouyn noranda
accompagne les entreprises à la
recherche de travailleurs étrangers ce
qui a permis d'en recruter une
cinquantaine les besoins sont là ils
sont grands nous on était capable d'en
tenir une partie mais encore beaucoup de
place pour répondre aux besoins des
entreprises plus de 4300 postes sont
présentement vacant en abitibi
témiscamingue
alors que le taux de chômage est au
plancher à 3 4% 2 points sous la moyenne
nationale
la situation était intenable selon la
ville de rouyn noranda et son centre
local de développement
ils réclament des chargements pour
faciliter le recrutement de travailleurs
étrangers alors on mise sur les
migrations économiques mais en quelque
part va falloir aussi que le
gouvernement allège certaines certains
processus parce que le sait c'est trop
difficile
depuis 2010 9,1 programme d'immigration
du gouvernement fédéral permet aux
communautés nordiques de sélectionner
elle-même des candidats pour la
résidence permanente selon leurs besoins
en main d'oeuvre ce programme est à
faire actuellement antennes sadri notre
pays tandis qu'ils sont tous également
des communautés minières très très
proche du site la résidence permanente
est assurée à l'intérieur de six mois
alors que si seul un processus qui va
jusqu'à 36 mois mais le programme n'est
pas offert au québec puisque c'est le
gouvernement provincial qui est en
charge de l'immigration économique on
souhaite que certains corps de métier
très en demande comme mécanicien ou
soudeur puissent bénéficier d'une voie
accélérée pour la résidence permanente
et que les exigences linguistiques
soient revus à la baisse
ce que québec a déjà fait dans le cadre
de programmes pilotes pour accueillir
des préposés aux bénéficiaires et des
travailleurs dans les secteurs de la
transformation alimentaire et des
technologies de l'information les postes
ont simplement à
être en francisation et n'ont pas
respecté les critères dans ce sens
certaines motivations qui peuvent
peut-être évaluer si tout va bien adria
devrait recevoir cet été les premiers
travailleurs qu'elle a recruté au
mexique et en colombie
l'entreprise leur verse déjà une aide
financière pour qu'ils commencent à
prendre le français cliquant tina qu'on
a sélectionné on le désire par chance de
voir venir s'établir
donc éventuellement souhaite qu'ils
puissent est à voir que ça une résidence
permanente puis de mairie pour nous plus
longtemps
malgré une première expérience décevante
aux concessionnaires automobiles
on a décidé de poursuivre le recrutement
des travailleurs étrangers cinq
mécaniciens marocains et tunisiens se
joindront à l'équipe d'ici cet été
marocains tunisiens je pense pas mais je
pense exact pas de barrière linguistique
on on a misé là dessus cette année on
souhaite qu'il s'établisse dans la
région pour de bon que le processus
d'immigration ne dépasse pas plié
bagages une autre province ici olivier
bachand à radio canada rouyn noranda